Alright guys, it's time to close the deal and before we get into the script and we get
into all of that, I want to share something, I want to give an analogy and this is the
way I want you guys to think about the clothes, okay?
And there's a reason why this module is actually fairly short, you're going to find it's relatively
digestible and that is because to stress once again, the clothes happens in the setup.
The way you do the setup, the better you do the setup, the easier the clothes and so that's
why I want to show you guys that this part right here should be easy.
This part should be you guiding them through the process, collecting the card and going
on to the next deal.
This should not be a huge thing, okay, if you've done it correctly.
But I want you guys to think about baking a cake and so I haven't baked a lot of cake
in my days and I really haven't baked that much at all, but I want you just to think
about it because you can imagine, right?
With a cake you have a recipe and the closer that you follow that recipe, the better the
cake is going to turn out as long as the recipe is good, right?
So I want you to think about the recipe being the process and the cake being a sale.
So here's what's cool about this specific process is you have probably noticed as I've
interviewed people and as people have come through this program, you've probably seen
that most of them when I do the interviews, they say just flat out, yeah, I messed up
70% of what I was supposed to do.
I messed up 20%.
I didn't do anything right and I still closed the deal.
So the beautiful thing about this specific process, our process here in Flat View Mastery
is you don't need to do it perfectly.
You actually don't need to do it perfectly.
All your goal is is you want to follow this recipe, which is the process.
You want to follow it as closely as you possibly can and the closer you can follow the recipe,
the closer you can follow the process, the more consistent your results are going to
be.
But what's interesting and what's crazy and what's pretty cool is that even if you don't
follow it exactly, you will still more often than not finish the process, finish the recipe
and you'll still have a cake.
And that's what's so cool about this whole process is we've seen people who do everything
wrong, right?
They don't get both business owners on the phone and they still close the deal or they
don't do the live transfer process correctly or they don't cover certain objections exactly
how they should have.
They don't do the zoom call at the right time, all these different things and they still
close the deal.
So I just want you to picture this, this entire process, but specifically this step.
We're trying to follow this exactly as it's laid out because I've done it enough times
where I know what the recipe is.
I know that if you do these certain things, you are going to get a deal.
So the closer you can get to following everything that I'm about to share and everything that
we've shared, we've shared up to this point, the more likely you are going to have the
same result every time, which is a nice, fat, juicy deal.
Do the best you can.
Don't sweat it.
Just send it every single time and you will get deals.